[Musique]
alors je voulais commencer par cette
merveilleuse photo ma beauté est
intérieure
en fait cette image est extraite d'une
campagne de sensibilisation et j'aime
beaucoup
elle me fait direct penser à un adage
attention hautement philosophique je
vais le dire doucement à trop vouloir
rentrer dans le moule on finit par
ressembler à une tarte à prônes loi
ressembler à une tarte
j'adore et j'ajouterais même on finit
par ne plus être qu'un produit
standardisé sans saveur sans caractère
sans histoire et sans lien est derrière
cette tare 10 à sion à mon avis il ya
bien trop d'aberrations parmi lesquels
le gaspillage et quand on dit gaspillage
on pense direct gaspillage ou à vous
êtes attaqué ce soir bravo
alors le gaspillage c'est un bien vaste
sujet il y à l'alimentation les énergies
les transports mais il ya aussi le gafi
le gaspillage humain
le gafi de compétences alors la bonne
nouvelle c'est que ça change et ça
commence par des petits pas de côté qui
permette de sortir de son pré carré
moi c'est ce gâchis humain qui m'a donné
l'envi de sortir du cadre de travailler
autrement de valoriser toutes ces
compétences gaffé et s'il y a quelques
années nous n'étions qu'une petite
poignée dans l' aventure aujourd'hui
c'est des dizaines de personnes qui
bougent avec nous hors du cadre
en 2008 j'ai participé à la construction
d'une structure un peu différente
vous savez de ces projets qui
instantanément déclenché une déferlante
d'incrédulité de ça ne marchera jamais
ce n'est pas possible parce que vous
n'avez pas pensé à bref un truc hors
norme
en fait l'idée était de créer une
association qui emploie en cdi à temps
plein en milieu ordinaire des personnes
en situation de handicap principalement
de la déficience intellectuelle pour
aller réaliser des prestations agricole
sur le territoire comme les vendanges
les plantations maraîchères
les récoltes voyez tout de suite ça pose
le décor pas d'éducateurs need encadrant
technique
nous voulions mettre en place une
démarche d'empowerment est en effet
depuis quelques années c'est sébastien
et jean michel2 de nos salariés qui sont
chefs d'equipe et qui en encadre
quotidiennement les salariés sur le
terrain figurez-vous qu'en plus nous
avions l'ambition de tendant vers
l'autonomie financière et de vivre de
produits de nos prestations et pour
couronner le tout la direction elle et
être assuré à l'époque par une jeune
femme parisienne je sais il faut pas le
dire en tout début de carrière et ce
dans un monde agricole lankais un monde
plutôt très très masculin disons alors
imaginez quand je suis arrivé avec ce
joli projet sous le bras et pourtant
aujourd'hui ça fait presque dix ans jour
pour jour disant que que cette structure
existe que cette belle équipe
travaillent quotidiennement en fait à
changer les lignes sortir du cadre dit
super collaborateurs avec qui j'ai eu la
chance de travailler et plein de belles
actions souvent à leur initiative en
fait ils interviennent dans les écoles
pour parler de leur handicap du handicap
on a également créé des jardins
thérapeutiques en fait dans les maisons
de retraite et on s'est dit qu'on allait
me que c'est ça avec des activités
périscolaires pour faire des ateliers
intergénérationnels
donc voilà de très belles actions qui
existent et qui se développe depuis dix
ans mais attention pas de langue de bois
le chemin n'est pas un long fleuve
tranquille
il peut même s'avérer en fait être une
bonne grosse traversée du désert vous
voyez du genre vous êtes tout seul dans
la vallée de la mort avec les petits
scorpions qui passe là bas un soir
j'étais tout seul dans mon petit bureau
à compter les petits scorpion un peu
fatigué a battu à penser à tous les murs
qu'il restait encore à faire tomber tous
les c'est impossible parce que
tu n'as pas pensé à toutes les factures
les salaires aussi à payer alors j'ai
pris mon téléphone et j'ai appelé ma
mère avec un bon gros besoin de
réconfort savait ce qu'elle m'a dit oui
mais bon enfin ma fille tu t'épuises là
tu gâches de meilleures années quand vas
tu trouvé un vrai métier un bon bain
pour les paroles réconfortantes je
repasserai non mais en fait je lui en
suis extrêmement reconnaissante merci
maman car ces paroles ont vraiment été
déterminante pour moi bon j'avoue en
d'abord la colère m'a bien traverser un
quoi un vrai métier sérieux un vrai
métier parce que je verrai une structure
qui permet l'emploi de personnes qui
jusqu'àlors été discriminés générer de
la valeur et participer à la dynamique
de monde mon territoire c'est pas vrai
métier mais j'ai compris alors pour ma
mère est pour certains un vrai métier
c'est un métier qui rentre dans les
cases institutrice médecin banquière
commercial que sais-je
moi mon métier ne rendent pas vraiment
dans les cases ni même dans les tiroirs
ou dans les commodes normandin et
l'étiquette est un peu difficile à
trouver
toujours dans mon petit bureau je me
suis demandé moi quelle étiquette
j'aimerais bien avoir faisait de
changement faisait de changement way je
me souviens j'avais dit à haute voix et
en souriant
bon bah déjà parce qu'avec mon cheveu
sur la langue vous l'aurez compris
faisait de changement c'est pas facile à
dire non mais vous rigolez mais pour
pouvoir le dire à peu près correctement
ce soir je me suis entraîné pendant six
mois mais les souris aussi parce que
cette idée c'était l'idée qui me faisait
vibrer et oui parce qu'on vit dans une
période de transition des technologies
incroyable apparaissent les
intelligences artificielles la conquête
de l'espace
mais heureusement sur mon activité qui
est finalement bien éloigné de cette
modernité
ben moi j'ai
juste fait un petit pas de côté en fait
c'est juste du bon sens des besoins
locaux et concrets qui peuvent répondre
mutuellement j'ai alors pensé à nouveau
aux paroles de ma mère tu gâches des
meilleures années la notion de gafi on y
revient elle est vraiment très
intéressante alors r/ga fait mes
meilleures années
je crois que c'est bien tout le
contraire en fait parce que j'ai créé
une structure me permettant d'exploiter
mon potentiel d'aller au delà de ma zone
de confort au delà d'organigramme
standard et de simple fiche de poste
et puis me permettant d'avoir la chance
d'être parmi vous ce soir également
de même pour mes salariés avant pour la
plupart ils étaient dans des structures
dites spécialisés avec finalement peu de
possibilités d'évolution et aujourd'hui
comme je disais certains son chef
d'equipe et comme les gens parlent
beaucoup mieux que moi et que j'aimerais
vraiment qu'ils puissent partager la
scène avec moi j'aimerais leur laisser
la parole quelques instants on cherche
une comme ça tu me trou dans la caisse
sébastien bourdais a été le tout premier
salarié embauché en cdi en 2008 il est à
présent chef d'equipe ça m'a permis
d'avoir un salaire ou un logement et des
enfants maintenant monsieur l'équipe
c'est vrai que c'est une chose de dire
formidable transmettre aux personnes qui
arrivent
mon savoir mais c'est vrai qu'au début
j'étais plus et j'étais comme eux
j'étais ouvrier
voilà donc certains comme sébastien son
chef d'equipe tout son responsable
sécurité responsable du matériel surtout
tous sont co décideur avec moi et ça
c'est tout sauf du gafi pour moi c'est
des collaborateurs incroyable ils sont
partie prenante force de proposition
d'une chance inouïe sans parler de
toutes les personnes qui nous
soutiennent qu'ils croient en nous qui
nous accompagnent qui sont à nos côtés
quotidiennement une reconnaissance
infinie et c'est vraiment tout sauf du
café pour moi à mon sens du gâchis
humain de gas field en vie dans les
entreprises il ya encore malheureusement
beaucoup et quand on parle de l'humain
c'est la personne bien sûr mais
c'est aussi notre cadre de vie notre
environnement notre alimentation
nos ressources et là aussi l'innovation
doit faire un pas de côté pour prendre
en compte tous ces enjeux le gaspillage
des ressources c'est mon second combat
ces notes second combat avec mon équipe
à mon sens il faut changer les modèles
existants pour optimiser l'utilisation
de nos ressources avec plus de sobriété
et d'efficacité pour en limiter le
gaspillage et les impacts
environnementaux mais sans oublier
d'optimiser le bien-être des individus
vaste programme en fait c'est exactement
ce qu'on appelle l'économie circulaire
et peu à peu on y vient et heureusement
parce que proposer des systèmes
alimentaires moderne permettant
d'approvisionner à toute heure du jour
de la nuit en tout lieu à travers tout
l'hexagone des structures ou collective
ou des restaurants ou des supermarchés
c'est super mais quand on a acheté nous
nos petites carottes toute pimpante bien
droite bien normes et tout standardisés
malheureusement on ne voit pas l'envers
du décor et l'envers du décor c'est ce à
quoi ça c'est les fruits et légumes des
classes et c'est le résultat des cahiers
des charges drastique des acheteurs des
verts en 2011 ça représentait 54% du
gaspillage alimentaire mondiale 54 %
c'est plus de 1,3 milliard de tonnes de
produits gaspiller et détruit chaque
année 1,3 milliard de tonnes
c'est 41 tonnes à la seconde par dit
comme ça on se rend pas bien compte mais
par exemple ce soir depuis le début de
mon intervention avec vous c'est plus de
22 mille tonnes de fruits et légumes qui
ont été gâchées et détruit 22 mille
tonnes et l'aberration suprême
maintenant c'est qu'avec seulement un
quart de ses 1,3 milliard de tonnes
gâcher on pourrait nourrir les 870
millions de personnes
qui meurent de faim chaque année avec
seulement un quart je sais pas vous mais
moi ça me fait froid dans le dos je
repense aux paroles de ma mère et mes
salariés et moi même les faiseurs de
changement mais nous savons a mis en
action on s'est dit qu'il fallait faire
quelque chose qu'on pouvait pas rester
comme ça quand je repense au potager de
mes grands parents aux fruits et légumes
qui nous fait manger trop gros trop
petit a fait tordue il avait exactement
le même goût dans mon assiette que les
top models du potager alors pourquoi la
restauration collective ne les récupère
t'elle pas ses produits déclassés or
calibre hors norme
la petite question avez vous déjà
récupéré une tonne de carotte une tonne
1000 kg directement du chant donc plein
de terre qu'il vous fallait brossé lavés
épluchés et découpés non pas en même
temps si quelqu'un me dit oui vous avez
des hobbies super inquiétant bon moi
j'ai dû le faire et est en fait ça
demande beaucoup de temps beaucoup de
personnel et des équipements adaptés
bref ce dont manque la restauration
collective aujourd'hui donc pour revenir
à des plans alimentaires cohérent et
territoriaux pour passer directement du
champ à l'assiette
il manque un autre intermédiaire un
atelier de transformation
eh bien nous l'avons créée avec mes
salariés en fin d'année dernière un
atelier de 450 m² alors c'est du bon
sens les sûr mais pas que il faut
changer en fait les systèmes en place
changer les pratiques faire de la
sensibilisation trouver des outils pour
structurer l'offre et la demande pour
pouvoir revenir à l'économie locale
circulaire et solidaire alors vous allez
me dire bah ouais mais ça marche comment
très concrètement en fait c'est une
entreprise
nous allons directement chez les
exploitants on leur a fait ses produits
déclassés
on leur achète des produits qui étaient
jusqu'à présent tu détruis gaspiller on
les récupère on les lave on les épluche
on les découpe en rap et en brunoise en
rondelles on les met sous vide cru prêts
à cuisiner ou à consommer et on les vend
aux restaurants collectifs comme la
cuisine centrale d'avignon
où les hôpitaux les maisons de retraite
qu'est ce que ça change
et bien moi depuis un peu moins d'un an
maintenant il ya 4000 petit écolier qui
mangent chaque jour des produits frais
locaux et de saison
et en plus avec leur repas tout une
démarche pédagogique et de
sensibilisation a été mise en place
sensibilisation au bout mais aussi à une
consommation plus durables parce que
c'est eux les faiseurs de changements de
demain
de même dans les hôpitaux les maisons de
retraite en fait les personnes âgées
fragilisées ou malades ont le plaisir de
savourer de bons potage frais aux
qualités nutritionnelles reconnues
lorsqu'avant il se voyait servir des
potages lyophilisée entre deux
compléments alimentaires et puis cette
activité d'ici trois ans en fête aura
généré un chiffre d'affaires permettant
de consolider les emplois de plus de 10
personnes en situation de handicap et
d'approvisionner plus d'un million de
repas sur le territoire et également de
réduire les émissions de gaz à effet de
serre de plusieurs centaines de tonnes
d'équivalent co2 voilà pour moi
l'économie autrement c'est ça et c'est
ça qu'un petit pas de côté peut faire
germer alors attendez je vous vois venir
ne vous méprenez pas je ne suis ni
masochiste ni investi d'une mission
sacrée
ce qui m'anime ce qui nous anime c'est
le plaisir le plaisir de co-créer de
partager l envie de sortir du cadre et
surtout l'envié de ne pas ressembler à
la fameuse tarte de l'adage une tarte
100 caractères et surtout générant
beaucoup de gars fier alors soyons
innovant soyons faiseurs de changement
ne nous privons plus du plaisir ne
gâchons plus nos potentialités ne
gâchons plus nos idéaux nos envies nos
idées et surtout ne gâchons pas les
potentialités des générations à venir
alors je vous invite tout à l'heure en
sortant lundi au boulot un dîner entre
amis en famille et bien à faire ce petit
pas de côté quelques soit parce qu'en
fait pour cultiver ce vaste champ des
possibles ça commence toujours par ce
petit pas merci
[Applaudissements]